auch wenn es da dramatische ereignisse
ein star das war's für maggie ein
anderer high school na klar das war eine
gute brücke jetzt rüber zu kalt und ja
der neue gesundheitsminister ist das
wissen wir seit heute und sowieso wissen
wir jetzt überhaupt wer alles im
kabinett sitzt die liste ist seit heute
vollständig es gab eben gerade eine
pressekonferenz mit olaf scholz dem
zukünftigen kanzler dort hat er alle
personalien die noch offen waren bekannt
gegeben und da war muss man sagen auch
die ein oder andere überraschung dabei
und er ist aber die größte überraschung
natürlich war dieser name voll im rennen
seit monaten aber irgendwie dachte man
und auch peter tiede dachte so unser
bild chefreporter und corona experte bei
uns im haus am ende wird olaf scholz
diesen mann nicht zu seinem minister
machen hat er doch gemacht sagt uns ein
bisschen was im moment von der stimmung
hier im politischen berlin das ist eine
richtige hammer personalie was hörst du
schon für reaktionen auf diese
entscheidung karl würz als sowie in der
bevölkerung also es gibt viele die sich
freuen viele die für olaf scholz auch
den hut ziehen weil sie sagen ist eine
schlaue entscheidung eine mutige
entscheidung weil karl lauterbach ist
kein einfacher mensch ist wirklich einer
der top-acts expert man kann es ihm
stehen wie man will aber keiner macht
war einer der großen krone erklärt einer
der der millionen leute mit an die hand
genommen hat und die sich bei dem sicher
gefühlt habe und durch die krone durch
die korona pandemie durch gebracht aber
er polarisiert halt auch von daher ist
eine mutige entscheidung olaf scholz
hatte viel erklären müssen wenn er ihn
nicht genommen hätte auch in der eigenen
partei auch in der bevölkerung und vor
allem wenn er dann eine expertin
genommen hätte also das hätte sonst eine
frau werth werden können dann expertin
genommen hätte die nicht den ruf hat wie
karl lauterbach dann wäre das auch für
diejenigen und für denjenigen schwer
geworden weil karl lauterbach quasi wie
so eine art neben gesundheitsminister
dann halt trotzdem da gewesen wäre und
karl lauterbach christo am besten
gebändigt in dem nur ein mindest dass
olaf scholz schlauerweise gemacht und im
politischen berlin es ist wie es ist wie
wie draußen also natürlich im
gesundheitsministerium also im stab von
jens spahn
im juli sieht definitiv anders aus und
in der union auch aber damit wird
deutschland leben müssen und ich glaube
karl lauterbach kann damit gut leben
oder scholz kann damit auch gut leben
und großteil von deutschland auch und
karl odermatt muss jetzt zeigen aber
auch minister kann und dass er in einer
phase die mehr als spannend und auch
zukunftsweisend für uns alle sein wird
jetzt in dieser phase der pandemie die
besonders angespannt ist für alle die
die ja die strategie von karl lauterbach
nicht so gut kennen als er uns einmal
wie positioniert er sich bei dem großen
thema corona das für ihn ja auch ganz
entscheidend verbesserte werden wird in
den kommenden wochen und monaten also es
gibt niemanden der in diesen zwei jahren
gerade positionen gehabt hätte er seine
position irgendwie halten konnte
natürlich auch karl lauterbach nicht
erstens könnte zum anfang niemand dieses
virus wusste nicht wie es sich verhält
man musste nicht wie die impfungen
wirken und wenn sie dann überhaupt
kommen auch karl lauterbach nicht alle
experten haben sich mindestens einmal
gerät kann auch das könnte auch zu denen
die sich ein oder zweimal getan aber
karl lauterbach hat immer die größe ich
hab das auch einzugestehen jetzt auch
mal bei bild eingestanden und karl
lauterbach ist nie jemand gewesen der
den total in london wollte also karl
lauterbach ist kein anhänger der no go
it strategien vieler experten auch mit
ihnen zusammenarbeitet sind für no go
wird das heißt also der region große
kampf das bisschen bis kein virus mehr
wie das und sich niemanden ansteckt also
alle durch im winter zwang da ist er
nicht dabei karl lauterbach ist unter
denjenigen die mahnen und vorsichtig
sind einer der moderaten und karl
lauterbach ist auch kein freund von
schul londons karl odermatt ist kein
freund von einem knappen london karl
lauterbach ist kein freund von total
dicht machen wieder was viele andere
andere wollen da hat er sich jetzt auch
jüngsten wirken gegen die
unions-ministerpräsidenten dann auch
gestellt und kann oder man ist auf dem
mittelweg sagen wir mal so die aber
jetzt weit weg von kubicki die planer
regieren ja jetzt künftig zusammen die
fdp und eben ja das ist ja in ordnung
das heißt die länder in der region ist
für die fdp erstmal damit dann glaube
ich hat gestern zwei mal vielleicht noch
ein drittes mal vielleicht kann sie auch
noch dran ich weiß es nicht aber das ist
schon wirklich das polarisiert aber wie
gesagt du kannst als minister dank nicht
sein eigenes ding machen also das was
anderes ob der am kabinettstisch und
eine volksschule schuss sitzt karl
lauterbach muss da sich umstellen er hat
es gestern schon mal eine will gemacht
die tonlage war ja schon ticken anders
er war auch aufgeräumt der sieht auch
aufgeräumter aus und der auftritt heute
war ja auch kurz also wirklich kurz und
knackig also wir haben kann oder mag
auch schon auf eine anders erlebt und
sag mal in deutschland wird sich
überraschen lassen von carlotta warum
glaube so geht es auch dem
kabinettskollegen und auch den ampeln
kollegen ist eine echte überraschung
dass überhaupt mal auf das gesamt
kabinett schauen das jetzt hier steht
denn da sind hier einigen anderen namen
noch bekannt geworden heute christine
lambrecht beispielsweise die wurde
gehandelt als künftige innenministerin
jetzt ist klar sie übernimmt das
verteidigungsministerium werden dass
einmal auf war bereits aufgearbeitet wo
man alle köpfe mal sehen kann dass
zukünftige kabinetts ist und wir auf
unserer rolle die brennt mir gleich mal
einer muss gar nicht erst römerlager
wiedergabe darauf können wir mal
gemeinsam einmal schauen die namen die
heute bekannt gegeben worden christine
lambrecht das habe ich schon einmal
gesagt jetzt also
verteidigungsministerium dass auch eine
große überraschung für die große
überraschung ich glaube auch für
christine lambrecht in den letzten tagen
die große überraschung sie war fest
eingeplant und wirklich gebucht als
innenministerin sie hat auch schon mal
vorgefühlt ins innenministerium rein
schlaue entscheidung weil olaf scholz
musste ja frauenüberschuss produzieren
damit unter ihm die parität hergestellt
ist in seinem kabinett also mit ihm ist
es nicht paritätisch aber unter dem des
paritätisch und also muss seine frau
verteidigungsministerin werden in dem
moment wo karl lauterbach oder einen man
halt in ein anderes ressort geht und
chrissy nicht einfach ist eine kluge
entscheidung weil es gibt keine
gestanden
verteidigungsexperten außer eva högl die
schon für ungut gesorgt hat als sie
wehrbeauftragte wurde und deswegen in
eine gestandene ministerin eine die sich
durchgesetzt hat und christine lambrecht
hat sich dieses hat sich in dieser
legislaturperiode durchgesetzt wir sehen
sich ja auch ich glaube das war auch ein
der interviews wo es um ein zentrales
thema gegen die mich um die verschärfung
strafrecht bei kinderpornografie und
kindesmissbrauch und da hat sie wirklich
gepunktet weil sie sich durchgesetzt
erstens war sie in der lage öffentlich
ihre eigene position zu überdenken das
zu vermitteln und das dann auch
durchzusetzen und das ist eine der
größten leistungen die der politik fall
bringen kannst nicht einfach durch die
wand drin und am ende sagen ich habe
gewonnen sondern wirklich so was man
also große überraschung große
entscheidung muss man sehen wie es in
der truppe ankommt aber zumindest ist ja
eine gegenposition zu den pazifisten ist
und noch einen namen muss sich
deutschland heute merken das ist nämlich
der name nancy faeser eine hessische spd
frau die jetzt die nachfolgerin von
horst seehofer wird im
bundesinnenministerium das seit
jahrzehnten im grunde seit otto schily
schwarz angemalt ist da rückt sie jetzt
eher ein diese frau wer ist das ja fotos
liefern was auch schon schwarz und sie
als erste wirklich als erste frau in
diesem amt und ja sie stand eigentlich
auf dem zettel spitzenkandidatin für die
landtagswahl in hessen führt für die spd
jetzt sind sie bei olaf scholz am
kabinettstisch eine kleine überraschung
aber wenn man genauer hinschaut das
haben wir ja auch erklärt noch mal bis
in alle einzelheiten sie ist wirklich
eine gestandene politikerin und wer den
weg gemacht den untersuchungsausschuss
dazu in hessen mit gemacht hat werden es
untersuchungsausschuss wirklich mit
geprägt hat wie sie wer damals auch
gestanden hat in diesem streit in
hessischen der hessischen politik als
damals in frau ypsilanti quasi abgeräumt
werden musste und das hat sie dann
relativ souverän gemacht und steht wohl
auch relativ gut in der fraktion selber
und ist auch ist auch anerkannt zum
beispiel hat folgen der kollege habe aus
der politik redaktion hat vorhin mit dem
chef der polizeigewerkschaft rainer
wendt gesprochen der gerne mal schimpft
und gerne mosert der nix zu meckern hat
gesagt ist die hat sie als
lösungsorientierte politikerin keinen
ganzen maßstab ist naja aber das hat
schon was es ist nicht wirklich das ist
ein harter wir sind konservativer hund
und wenn der sagt ja wohl herzlich
willkommen gut gute wahl dann muss man
erst mal sagen okay dann scheint es auch
eine gute wahl zu sein dass also der
spannenden blick ins kabinett das jetzt
vollständig ist seit diesem heutigen
tage peter tiede vielen herzlichen dank
für deinen besuch hier im studio